supporting an ally abroad addressing
economic concerns at home the president
sought to reassure americans about the
massive 33 billion dollar package he's
requesting the cost of this fight
is not cheap
but caving to aggression is going to be
more costly if we allow it to happen
we either back ukrainian people as they
defend their country or
we stand by as the russians continue
their atrocities and aggression in
ukraine
most money is for military aid some
humanitarian he's also asking congress
to approve further sanctions on russian
oligarchs we're going to seize their
yachts their luxury homes and other
ill-begotten gains
with russia now warning the west that
arming ukraine will threaten european
security the u.n secretary general
visited the scene of civilian killings
near kiev i imagine my family
in one of those houses
that is now destroyed
and black
i see my my granddaughters
running away in panic
part of the family eventually killed
so the war
is an absurdity in the 21st century
president zielinski says he's grateful
for all external help the uk's foreign
secretary is urging allies to ramp up
military production despite warnings
from moscow
if someone intends to interfere from the
outside and there are threats of a
strategic nature they must know that our
response to counter-strikes will be
lightning fast rapid we have all the
tools we need the kind that no one else
can boast about and we will not boast
we'll use them
it's up to congress now but the scale of
president biden's ask suggests he's
hopeful of bipartisan support that he
won't be deterred by threats from moscow
and that he knows america is in this for
the long haul whether it wants to be or
not
there's pressure on congress to act
quickly the president claiming this
support will not only help ukraine but
ultimately benefit america
and boost global security
david blevins sky news washington